thank you um so does the joint work with
a bunch of people there's a nice story
about this which I'll hopefully get to
soon it's also helpful to have paid
attention it's s talks but not necessary
okay no offense okay so I'm actually
going to start from a string matching
problem I like strings and the problems
that arise in string matching and
particularly particular we will be
talking about a virus detection problem
so imagine you have a router and you
have a lot of data going through the
router and you want to detect viruses
typically what network network intrusion
detection systems use our digital
signatures and what they do is within
the router they search within the
streaming data they search for digital
signatures to alert intrusion alert you
know someone's trying to do something
bad to the system okay and a bottleneck
that it reappears in the industry is
trying to deal with this problem is what
i like to call gap signatures so what
does this mean so viruses don't
necessarily digital signatures or
viruses don't necessarily appear in a
consecutive area in the stream of data
they might appear scattered throughout
the stream and the other issue is that
we have to report viruses as soon as
they appear right we don't want to say
Oh yesterday there was a virus in the
stream it might be too late right so we
want to port them as soon as they we see
them here's a virus okay so one way of
visualizing this is let's say this is
some text or a stream of data that's
coming through and we might have some of
the digital signature over here and a
little bit later we might have the other
part of the doodle digital signature and
we somehow want to be able to to express
that oh you know we found this digital
signature so in order to be able to do
this in this streaming model we need
some method of so-called remembering
what happened in the past what has
appeared in the past maybe a long time
ago right and know that these things are
connected somehow in these comprised of
digital signature okay to make things
even worse is that reality has some
serious constraints this is true for
many aspects in life and here as well
Texas screaming very very fast we want
to react very quickly to each character
or each other new packet or character
ever you want to look at this and we
cannot use a lot of space in the
streaming model or in real life also
right we have routers they have limited
amount of space usage which is a
constraint on the system okay so this is
a can be formulated as a screaming
problem while mentioning a few more
things so if you look at the actual
digital signatures that needs d'être
contributing detection systems try to to
detect about ninety-five percent 5% of
them only have one gap so what I mean by
one gap so a gap pattern is the
following form it has two sub patterns
p1 and p2 and we're going to put a
special symbol over here which is going
to be the gap symbol that says you know
this symbol matches any substring of any
length even zero length substring okay
and now we can give a model this problem
as a theory with the algorithmic problem
so we call this the online dictionary
matching with one gap or the odd mog
problem it sounds like a name of
something from Harry Potter we want to
pre-process d gap patterns each pattern
has just one gap and give it an online
text one character at a time we want to
be able to report matches of these gap
patterns as soon as they appear we don't
want to wait like we said before we want
to report them as soon as they appear ok
so this is the odd mock problem and
there's a bit of a story time now ok so
this was just some theoretical you know
some background but let's talk about
some stories so the motivation of this
line of research was actually from
report by some company whose name I
won't mention about this problem from
the industry and they were telling us
you know this is a real problem how do
we solve this can you help us out you
have some ideas from theory you know
maybe you guys can you know you guys are
working on a string problems maybe you
can help us figuring how to solve this
problem so we did come up with some
solutions and the solutions either had a
lot of space which was not practical so
they're not interesting or they could
use low space but required square root
of D time per character so d is the
number of gap patterns and the number of
gap patterns is really really large
square root of D is huge is not
something
were willing to to accept and practice
right so this is not good okay so tens
of thousands a lot of viruses up there
so the question is is this necessary
right like okay we work really hard we
can't seem to beat the square root of D
is just really necessary in some way can
we prove a lower bound and the answer
turn out to be yes at the same time
we're working on some three some pot
some problems and we notice you know we
prove some reduction showing that if you
can be square root of D then you can
solve through some faster than quadratic
time okay so this is really bad news for
practical aspects of the problem so
maybe we can still somehow do better and
practice and turns out that yes we can't
do better in practice so the threesome
lower bound instance is dense this is
touches a bit of what's F spoke about
earlier but real data is actually sparse
and we came up with a new algorithm
where the cost per character depends on
the sum sparseness measurement we'll
talk about this later of the input right
so for sparse cases we can actually do
things very very quickly okay and then a
natural question to ask well can we do
better than the sparsity measurement or
is this varsity measurement somehow
necessary and again the answer is yes
and again we show a reduction a lower
bound from 3some showing that for any
input any type of any graph any family
of graphs with the specific sparsity
there are instances where solving them
faster than just as a sparsity time
would solve 3some faster than quadratic
time okay so it looks pretty positive
right a lots of yeses so the the rest of
the talk is really going to eventually
reach triangle enumeration problems and
we're going to be talking about upper
and lower bounds for these and this all
relates back to this odd mog problem
online dictionary matching with one gap
okay so unfortunately the odd mog
problem has some other inherent
difficulties that come from the fact
that it's a string problem you know some
sub patterns might be suffixes or
prefixes of some other sub patterns and
you have to
deal with with these things happening at
the same time so we're going to simplify
the at least this presentation today I'm
going to be focusing on a simplified
version of this problem which can
actually review that's a graph problem
so this is what I call the new sub graph
problem so we're given an input a graph
G and we want to pre-process it so that
afterwards were given a set of vertices
k vertices we can quickly output all the
edges induced by this list of vertices
or set of vertices so for example we
might have to scrap over here and we can
pre process graph and then we're
forgiven these queries these black
vertices and will output these four
edges all right these are the edges
induced by these black vertices ok um ok
so i'm going to show you now hopefully
show how if we have a solution for odd
mog then we can solve into sub graph
it's a very simple reduction so for each
vertex in the graph will create a
character and for each edge UV in the
graph will create to gap patterns you
star V and V Star you and here's an
example so this is a graph from before
so you can see for example for the edge
de over here we created these two
patterns over here this is a set of
patterns are we going to pre-process
using an algorithm for odd manque ok
just believe me that this covers
everything ok and now so this is the
first part of the reduction then how to
reduce a query so given to the set of
vertices v 13 BK well create a text with
just the the characters v 1 through VK
and will saul will look for this tag for
all the patterns within this text so
again in this example if this is a query
that we had before these black vertices
and we can create this text over here
and output these specific these specific
patterns which correspond exactly to
these specific edges which are exactly
the output of the induced sub graph
problem the reason of course we do we
create two patterns for each edges to
deal with directions right okay so
clearly odd mog solves induced sub graph
so for the rest of the talk i'm going to
focus just on the new sub graph problem
mentioning you know
with some more algorithmic techniques we
can also solve odd mog with come
comparable comparable running times but
let's just so focused on the use of
graphic because it's easier to reason
about and one more thing is that the
induced sub graph problem the input is a
set of vertices so now we're going to
assume that it's a list of vertices and
the vertices arrive one by one so we're
turning it into an online sort of
problem yes in the original motivation
it is it the case that you would have
the bi-directional thing with no but
it's you can overcome this by creating a
bipartite graph and gaining some order
ok um alright so just to this will be
helpful but for later so i'll be showing
you now a very simple there are several
algorithms that obtained square root of
d that i mentioned before which is
square root of M the number of edges in
the graph over here using techniques
date back to the 70s there's nothing
really exciting about this but they give
some insight as to what's going on a
little bit later so we'll say so this is
a solution for the induced sub graph
problem we'll say a vertex is heavy if
it has a least square root of M
neighbors and light otherwise and for
each of the heavy vertices will create a
maintain some list of all the light
neighbors that have appeared in the
current query of the induced sub graph
right so for a vertex to be that arrived
first market that his has arrived and if
it is light then we're going to scan all
of its neighbors doesn't have a lot of
neighbors we can afford to do that and
we'll check if they're marked as well if
they're market as well we list
appropriate edges also our neighbors if
I name of the neighbor V is heavy then
we add V to the list this list over here
we add V to the list of neighbors that
have appeared for the neighbor okay if V
is heavy then we have this list of all
these neighbors that have already
appeared we just output them that's easy
and we also scan the most square root of
M heavy neighbors that we might have
right then we'll square root of M since
the number of heavy vertices is bounded
by square root of M it's kind of at most
M over square root of M heavy vertices
in total on the graph so the taller one
time of this is just going to be a bunch
of square root of Em's and the size of
the output which might be really large
because
of this part over here okay simple
algorithm nothing too exciting about
this okay and again like I mentioned
before this algorithm plus some more
algorithmic techniques also you can
solve odd magan similar run times so the
question is can we do better and there
are two answers one is no 11 is yes no
because of a threesome lower bound
showing that you have to spend square
root of M time for the induced sub graph
problem assuming linear pre-processing
and yes if we use some better parameters
which goes back to the sparsity
measurements that I mentioned before so
let's first talk about the threesome
lower bound and I'll just give a quick
recap of what's that intersection is so
set this joint is first of all likes s
mentioned before we're given a family of
sets f the total size is capital n we
have Q pairs of sets so we want to
decide for each pair of SAS if they
intersect or not if the sets are
disjoint or not now remember this is
very important to remember this is an
offline problem right we don't receive
the queries one at a time we receive all
the queries at one plus one batch
together with the input and want to
solve everything at once okay the the
version of set intersection problems at
all going to be using right now is set
intersection so we want to enumerate the
output not just decide if two sets
intersect but look at the intersection
and enumerate all of all of the elements
in the intersection this turns out to be
very very useful and again recapping
some of what Seth said in the previous
talk so we showed that for all fine sand
intersection with an instant size right
we have these two parameters Delta and
gamma but an input size capital n so the
low case n here is the threesome N and
the capital n is the instance of the
center section okay it's important to
realize so the instant size is lowercase
n to the 3 plus Delta minus gamma over
to the query size is the number of
queries we want to answer it enter the 1
plus gamma the sides of the output is n
to the 2 minus Delta and we get this
lower bound and you don't have to really
absorb this now this is just to remember
what the so capital n Q and T are
parameters we might care about
um something which is helpful maybe
intuitively is to notice that gamma
controls the sparsity of the inputs okay
for some meaning of sparsity for some
definition of sparsity interestingly
over here we can actually can you take
gamma 2 equals 0 in this case as opposed
to the scepter showing this case that's
f talked about earlier where it has to
be strictly larger than 0 and Delta
controls the output size right n to the
two on this Delta so larger gamma means
more sparse and larger Delta means less
elements in the output okay all right so
take a graphic presentation of this
intersection problem so we have you know
some sets here in a some sets here and
see might be the same sets and we'll do
the natural well add natural so we have
your all the elements in the universe at
vertices for them as well will do the
natural thing of connecting each set
with all of the elements within the set
both from a and from C so this is a
quick social experiment who sees the
Starship Enterprise here okay we got a
winner if you tilt your head to the
right a bit
no yeah okay anyway so we have these
sets over here and the sets over here
connected to the elements over here and
queries are just edges if you're
interested in some queries so we can add
edges between A&C corresponding to the
set intersection queries that we want to
be able to answer now when our case from
you know using the 3sum hard instances
we get the number of edges over here is
exactly the number of queries which is n
to the 1 plus gamma the number of edges
over here between this part in this part
is this term over here and the size of
the output is going to be enter the 2
minus Delta right just remind you again
so one thing that we can quickly realize
is that if we consider this edge over
here and look at all of the triangles
have contained this edge this
corresponds exactly to all the elements
in the intersection of these two sets
all right that's that's easy to reason
about okay so low in general if we could
enumerate all the triangles in this
graph we could solve this offline set
intersection problem right so let's talk
about triangle innovation and see what
we can say about it so the triangle
racial problem is we're given a graph
with M edges and we want to enumerate
all the triangles okay and a theorem
that i'm going to quickly proved right
now is that a time where this algorithm
for them 78 which takes em m is the
number of edges to the 1.5 time is
essentially optimal meaning that we
don't expect an M to the 1.4 9999
algorithm okay so essentially optimal
means ignoring all sub polynomial
factors okay so if we take gamma 2 10
toward zero sorry gamma 2 tensor is a
third and Delta 2 tends toward zero
towards zero then we'll get that the
size of our instance here the number of
edges over here is going to be n to the
four thirds the number of edges are we
here between a and C is going to be n to
the four thirds the size of the output
is also going to be n to the fourth
roots things work out very nicely and
now we see that well if the number of
edges then to the four thirds and I have
to spend n square time to memorize all
the triangles because the solvus
eventual yourselves 3some
then we have to spend em to the 1.5 time
in total in terms of the number of edges
right and to the four thirds so we have
to spend enter the two thirds which is
square root of M time for each one of
the edges okay another interesting thing
to point out here is that the time poor
triangle in this case turns out to be
square root of M same reasoning the
number of triangles in the graph is n to
the four thirds so we need to spend into
the two thirds which is square root of M
time for triangle this is in contrast to
my hypo Trask whose result where he
showed from the 3sum conjecture that you
have to spend em to the third time so
this is slightly higher lower bound
which is great ok so we spoke about this
offline problem of triangle enumeration
and we kind of just and okay there is
some optimal algorithm we could also
consider two data structure versions of
triangle enumeration problems so one is
an edge triangles query and one's a
vertex triangle career let's see what
they mean so in a triangle query this is
what I mentioned earlier we want to
pre-process a graph this is again this
is data structure problem now okay it's
an online problem we pre process as a
graph so that given an edge we can
quickly enumerate all the triangles
containing the specific edge okay so I
think it's very natural to see that this
solves set intersection right you can
actually show that both of these
problems are equivalent completely
equivalent there are two ways reduction
so it's not difficult at all through
these wedge triangles queries what I
think is interesting to consider is the
vertex triangles craze so here it's
somewhat of a compliment problem we're
given a vertex and I'm worried all the
triangles containing this vertex okay so
there are two natural types of queries
so what can we say about them so i can
mention or any edge strangle crews are
equivalents an intersection and there's
a typical way of showing condition lower
bounds for enumeration problems from
from threesome in general when we talk
about your condition lower bounds not
just from threesome but also from
boolean matrix multiplication or
orthogonal some way looking at our
normal vectors are also looking at on
the matrix vikram
so all these problems kind of go down to
asking a similar question about you know
edge triangles queries but what I want
to talk about today is focus more on
vertex triangles queries and there's
some sense like we said a complement of
center section and interpretation is
that we consider specific element in the
universe and you want to enumerate all
the queries for which the specific
element is part of the output right and
this doesn't seem to fit nicely with
other popular conjectures maybe with one
exception so it seems like we really
need threesome to be able to say
something about this because of the
offline problem that we consider before
and we'll see soon how this helps us
okay so let's show a lower bound for
vertex triangle prairies of course is
going to be based on the offline problem
of new marine oil triangles right you
can always solve the offline problem new
marine all triangles by entering vertex
triangle queries on each one of the
vertices over here all right we could
solve threesome this way ok so again
we're going to take gamma to be tending
towards a third slightly larger and
Delta's going to be attending towards
zero and the number of vertex triangle
queries is going to be the size of the
universe so if you do the math aside the
universe comes out to be enter the
two-thirds ok and this means that either
the pre-processing time has to be the
time it takes to enumerate all triangles
anyway just numeral triangles and
prepare all the answers in advance or
the query time has to spend well this is
a number of queries that each one of
these degrees has to spend n into the
Four Thirds time which is exactly the
number of edges right which basically
means that a query will cost linear time
right that's all so trivial right so one
of these trivial things has to happen
which is quite unfortunate for these
type of queries ok so let's see how this
helps us onwards so let's just actually
before that let's recap quickly what
we've said so far so we basically
claimed that 3some reduces to offline
San intersection which reduces the
triangle information which reduces to
vertex triangle
data structure and the conclusion is
that either the pre-processing time
needs to be m2 the 1.5 or a query ty
needs to be linear m okay so what I'm
going to show you next is that and this
connects us back to what we said before
is that a vertex triangle data structure
is reduced into sub graph and then we
can say something about induced sub
graph and also a hog POG okay so how do
we do this this is also not too
difficult so we preprocessor graph or
induced sub graph queries and now we
want to use this data structure for and
do subtype prairies to answer vertex
triangles queries so what we do is when
we want to answer a query on the vertex
V we just input all the neighbors of V
into the induced sub graph data
structure and there's a clear by
junction between the edges in the output
and triangles that contains V right if
there's a triangle between two of my
neighbors if there's an edge between two
of my neighbors then that has to be a
triangle okay and this works backwards
as well okay so what kind of lower bound
do we get from this simpler reduction so
let's say D is a degree of V then either
the pre-processing time is still the
same as it was before you know
preprocess all the possible you know em
to the 1.5 time or the query time so
previously for the induced sub graph
problem was mo verse for the vertex
triangles problem it was just m+ order
plus csi's of the output over here we
have to divide by D since this is an
amount of time that we spend per vertex
in the induced sub graph problem so and
their d vertices so we're gonna have to
spend em over the time where the lower
bound is reduced by d
okay so there are natural question to
ask is well how big is d right the
larger d is the worse it is for us
because we get a weaker lower bound so
let's look back at our graph and if we
look at the number of edges and we
divide by the number of vertices we get
that the average degree is going to be m
to the 0.5 okay and if you plug this
back in over here then we're going to
get a square root of M lower bound for a
query time for each vertex right which
translates to square root of D for the
odd mock problem for the string virus
detection problem okay so this seems
like pretty bad news at least if you're
interested in practical algorithms right
after all these reductions we get this
lower bound and a natural question to
ask is why is this happening why do we
get to slower bound why what's what's
you know other than just reducing it
from three summers or anything else that
we can hang on to to say you know maybe
we can do better and if you look a
little bit carefully the graph instances
that give the square root of M lower
bound are very very dense and in
practice the graphs are very very sparse
in particular for virus detection
they're very very sparse so we would
like to find some other algorithm some
algorithm who's run time depends on
sparsity and of course doesn't
contradict the 3some lower bound okay
and these are one well the answer is yes
so now we're going to talk a little bit
of an upper bound and the upper bound
uses orientations so open parenthesis so
orientations the orientation problem is
we're given an undirected graph as input
and we want to output a directed graph
and the goal of what was through by
orienting the edges and the goal is to
have a low out degree so for example you
know the out degree of this node over
here this vertex over here is going to
be 3 the indegree might be very very
large but the goal is to have a a really
small out degree the maximum altec we
should be as small as possible okay
so a very natural term with which is
relevant to orientation problems is the
arbor icity of a graph so the adversity
of graph is the smallest number of
forests into which the set of edges can
be partitioned into spanning forests and
it's also closely related to other
sparsity measurements like the graph
degeneracy or the strength of the width
and suit arbor city as well so if you've
seen any of these or basically up to
constant factors all the same and
there's also naturally improved that the
upper receipt is also it's another
natural way of looking at it the density
of the most dense sub graph dense is sub
graph there's a minus one here that has
to do with the fact that it's far as but
if you just ignore this mining once you
get an intuition you consider all
possible sub graphs and you look at the
number of edges divided Amanda number of
vertices and the densest sub graph
defines the are porosity of the graph
okay um ann-arbor see shows up in a lot
of applications so there are a lot of
well-known bounded graphs of but net
well-known down in diversity graphs like
all you know all far is planar graphs
graphs of bikes through the minor can
all be shown to have a constant R
versity there's no really dense area in
the graph okay and how does related to
orientations well enough just going back
right so the brisket is a smallest
number of forests into which it can be
partitioned so let's say we somehow find
is partitioning into forests we could
orient each farce to have out degree one
just for each connected component which
is a tree pick one of the vertices to be
the root and orient all of the edges
towards a root right so the a degree is
going to be at most one and then we just
merge all the oriented forests together
so the a degree is going to be a mostly
Arbor icity okay there's a link so this
is a little bit difficult to do because
finding if partitions efficiently seems
hard to do at least we don't know
actually be careful about seems hard
today we don't know what you do it
faster than something like cubic time
but there are linear time algorithm is
obtaining the two approximation ok so
the ad maximum degree of every vertex
going to be at most twice diversity ok
and that we can talk about the upper
bound for this induced sub graph problem
so each vertex maintains the i should
say we orient the graph using this this
order of alpha G out degree orientation
and that we do the following so each
vertex going to maintain a list of all
of its incoming neighbors that have
already appeared similar to the heavy
nodes have you for disease in the
previous algorithm now whenever it takes
via arrived then we we first list all
the edges of vertices in the list right
if any of my incoming neighbors have
already appeared they should let me know
that they have appeared somehow so I
just list this apartments part of my
output and then we scan outgoing edges
right we have the most order of alpha G
edges to scan and we output what's
needed to be output ok so the total time
is going to be order of the arbor icity
plus the size of the output right this
is really great news because in practice
the aborigines really really low ok so
what do we know about the new sub graph
problem now well if we assume when
you're promising linear pre-processing
we have an upper bound of order of the
arbor icity and a lower bound of order
Omega square root of M from the
threesome conjecture and how the to
coexist well it is it's easy to prove
that their velocity is always a most
square root of M so for really really
really dense graphs yes this is the
lower bound right one of the things that
I don't like about lower bounds is that
they seem to hide some some of the words
the difficulty really lies right so it's
enough for one point of the function to
be a lower bound to say that this
function is a lower bound right so this
is a lower bound but it's lower bound
only because in the dense case it's a
lower bound but for sparse cases it
might not be and sometimes just by
looking at the function in claiming this
function is the lower bound we hide
what's really going on behind behind the
function so what we can actually prove
is I'll just summarize this in words
that if we could do faster than this
alpha G to the same 1 minus epsilon then
for any Alpha drink for any for any
dependency of alpha on the number of
edges in the graph then we could solve
that this will refute the threesome
conjecture
right so what we managed to also show is
that this is also the best we can do for
any sparsity any polynomial sparsity
right so you don't have special
algorithms for really dense cases in
which was Clifford before or really
sparse cases maybe do something even
faster ok and this ties up with another
line of work so we showed that you know
a bunch of other triangle numeration
problems are also optimal so I mentioned
before the entire mode is odd rhythm
from 78 to the M to the 1.5 is
essentially optimal cheap and esha Zeki
showed an algorithm that runs in order
of M times the arbor city of the graph
and we actually managed to improve this
a little bit by shaving some log factors
recently this is with Seth and theft
petty and Ellie pirat and is also a
recent paper by bjork lend pay Virginia
Williams and during this week where they
showed an output sensitive algorithm for
listening only t triangles this is a
type of run time that they get assuming
that the matrix multiplication constant
is too and we also managed to show this
is essentially optimal now this was
actually not possible to show from
through some conjecture using type at
roscoes ideas because you kind of get
stuck over here and you can't say
anything about this part yeah ok so the
conclusion of this is you know we match
to show an efficient solution for
induced sub graph which also leads to
the efficient solution for British
triangle queries which is optimal and on
the one hand and also we can extend
these ideas to solve odd mock
efficiently not practical inputs with
some more algorithm machinery as soon as
a really great example of how
understanding theory and understanding
where the difficulty comes from ends up
leading to practical algorithms we also
met also managed to show that a bunch of
offline triangle numeration algorithms
are essentially optimal and we show so
we spoke about vertex triangles but SF
mentioned we have an unpublished paper
on publish result that shows that ed
triangle queries we have an upper bound
that meets low around as well for the
entire spectrum assuming the 3sum
conjecture so basically it seems like at
least as far as threesome is concerned
we know a lot about
triangle invasion problems from you know
things are pretty much tight up to some
polynomial factors okay so i guess the
one open question that i keep getting
back to is okay so great so we know from
the 3sum conjecture that these things
are hard it's hard to do better but
maybe you can use other popular
conjectures to show lower bounds for
virtuous triangles or for induced sub
graph and let me point out where i see
the difficulty being if you want to
think about this to give you what you
don't want to listen to me but i just
get in the way right but so a vertex
triangle query has a flavor of an outer
product right if you look at matrix
multiplication if you consider set
intersection as as multiplying two
matrices where one matrix is sets and
elements and the other matrix is
elements and sets elements and sets then
vertex triangle queries in some sense
correspond to outer products okay but
the gnomes popular you know the Nolan
conditional over on techniques we use
may be related problems don't seem to
suffice because they're really about
inner products so there seems to be this
gap between what we know yeah we know
how to say things about inner products
which really correspond to set this
drawing this queries or setting for
section queries and it'd be really nice
to somehow relate these outer products
into these problems as well okay yeah
that's it thank you
we had lots of times for gracious
you mentioned that this you gave a
conditional lower bound for triangle
enumeration of Omega 1 to the M to the
1.5 assuming the 3sum conjecture but I
wondered what is known just of a
notoriously about the maximum number of
triangles in a graph with n nodes and
edges it's the most time to the 1.5 I
click for example the worst case you
have that number then that would be an
unconditional Louisville right so one
thing which I maybe should have
emphasized more is that the conditional
browns are not because of the number of
triangles a number of triangles is
probably normally less than the
conditional or brown that we get if you
recall it's a long way going back but
since we have time anyway
we look at the center section problem
here we go the size of the output has to
be polynomially less than n squared in
order for all of these lower bounds to
make sense right if the size of the
output to somehow and Squared's and just
a new raining all the elements and all
the intersections it's going to cost and
square and like you say you get a
trivial lower bound so the number of
edges is strictly less than N squared as
well you can somehow reason about that
it's possible that in your application
into the treehouse is larger than the no
no because you can always show that the
number of triangles is also at most M
times the arbor city of the graph right
so for each query that you asked you'd
have to spend in most diversity that's
conditional well there's an uncompressed
yeah so yeah but what's hope going on
over here is that we have this gap over
here which is you know the number of
triangles or decides the output is
polynomial s and the lower bound right
it is possible that the lower bound
really is the amount of time that you
need to spend per triangle and not the
rest of the stuff right so you have you
have in a query a lot of queries have
this um some set amount of time they
have spent for the query and then each
element in the output you have to spend
some time reporting it so it's possible
that a lower bound is actually on the
number amount of time you have to spend
on reporting a query and which in this
case would be into the Delta and not on
the sign and reporting which would be n
to the Delta and not on the quarry part
the the set query amount of time you
spend per query so maybe you can spend
less much less in square root of M but
the time if you spend a lot of time on
the output
almost there all right maybe maybe over
here it should be constant and it should
be output time something as a lower
bound
so you mention something of a towards
the end about the outer product versus
in a sort of someone without your
product problem that you can for me take
up space I don't have one I'm looking
for one right that's a yeah I mean one
way of looking at this is that you can
solve bmm you doing but by performing a
boolean matrix multiplication by
computing the outer product of each one
of the elements in the universe and then
you get N squared matrices and you have
to spend endtime sorry you get n
matrices each of size n squared which is
the output of each one of these other
products and then have to somehow to to
add them all together right so just this
computational time means you get nothing
from the reduction just a comment of
computation that you perform the
reductions already n cubed right that's
the only place where I saw some
connection to outer products other
problems don't seem to really give up me
be q es to do something quadratic
equation systems but
no longer believed to be hard okay so
never mind
you